en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía y por ello está en el
estudio Ya mi compañera Daniela hablando
Daniela bienvenida Muchas gracias Andrés
Daniela vamos a empezar en Ecuador en
días previos a la aplicación de la
llamada muerte Cruzada por parte del
presidente Guillermo lasso el tema
económico cobra fuerte protagonismo
Claro que sí pues los más desconfiados
Pensarán que esto no es una coincidencia
sin embargo los hechos indican que las
dos semanas que antecedieron a este
anuncio del presidente Guillermo lasso
estuvieron repletas de anuncios en un
país que se ha caracterizado por su
relativa estabilidad económica por un
lado la reforma tributaria no es nueva
una semana atrás había sido radicada con
carácter urgente en el parlamento de
mayoría opositora y ahora puede
enfrentar desafíos legales en tanto que
fue decretada unilateralmente por lazo
en el marco de este nuevo escenario
político sin pasar por el trámite
legislativo pero días Antes
había hecho el mayor canje de bonos por
deuda de la historia para proteger las
Islas Galápagos en una operación que fue
aplaudida por muchos y rechazadas
también por otros el país también firmó
un acuerdo comercial con china hace
pocos días y fue invitado por la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo a volver al grupo tras su
salida el primero de enero de 2020
recordemos que en ese momento se había
ido de este Club tras quejarse de las
cuotas impuestas por el organismo
internacional con sede en Viena vamos a
cambiar de tema de Daniela y nos vamos a
ir a Estados Unidos con uno de los temas
que marca la agenda allí es que es para
este fin de semana se espera que se
llegue a un acuerdo sobre el techo de la
deuda están negociando contrarreloj
Andrés el presidente está en Japón para
participar el fin de semana del acuerdo
de la Cumbre del g7 Aunque suspendió
otros viajes y se comprometió a volver
el mismo domingo para retomar los
diálogos directos con la oposición esto
dice la oposición precisamente
nuestra deuda Es mayor que nuestra
economía en más del 20% si no hacemos
nada pagaremos más intereses en los
próximos 10 años de lo que pagamos en
los últimos 83 si no hacemos nada y Dios
no lo quiera digamos un incumplimiento
por culpa de biden es porque él Ignora
el problema al igual que ignoró la
frontera mi Noris Justin le dije señor
presidente podríamos comenzar nuestras
reuniones durante 104 días dijo que no
Dani una de las grandes preguntas es qué
pasará si hay incumplimiento desde el
primero de junio ya se empieza a barajar
este escenario y es que ese día los 26
mil millones de dólares que ingresen por
impuestos solamente ese día no serían
suficientes para cubrir los alrededor de
100 mil millones de dólares en
obligaciones de gasto entre Quienes se
quedarían esperando sus cheques estarían
los proveedores médicos de Medicare que
es el programa de seguro médico Público
de Estados Unidos para personas mayores
los soldados tampoco recibirán pago
después vendrían los jubilados y otros
beneficiarios del seguro social y así
sucesivamente unos 150 CVS enviaron
también una carta abierta biden
expresando su preocupación por este tema
Dale vamos a cambiar de tema nuevamente
vamos a hablar de Rusia y Ucrania que
acordaron renovar su acuerdo de granos
Pues el ya confirmó que extendió este
acuerdo del
mar del mar Negro durante dos meses
inicialmente
Moscú no parecía dispuesto a extender
este pacto que se vencía justamente hoy
a menos que se cumpliera una lista de
demandas con respecto a sus propias
exportaciones agrícolas este jueves el
gobierno de Vladimir Putin dijo haber
logrado algunos resultados en las
conversaciones que le habían dado
ciertas esperanzas aunque no dio
detalles y sí aseguró que se deben hacer
más progresos para promover sus propios
intereses
Ella es una mipola qué estúpidos fuimos
al no entender que antes de la guerra
vivíamos en el paraíso había todas las
condiciones para la producción agrícola
en los últimos dos o tres años hasta
2022 el precio de las oleaginosas casi
se ha duplicado y el precio del trigo
estaba entre 250 y 320 dólares en la
tonelada Bueno hoy la tonelada cuesta
160 dólares en mi opinión está extensión
es otra pequeña Victoria que puede
convertirse en una derrota en cualquier
momento si Rusia vuelve a retrasar las
inspecciones de barcos e inspección a
cada barco diez veces retrasando todo el
proceso
y vamos a pasar a Reino Unido hay
preocupación entre los fabricantes de
vehículos porque por el brexit nada más
y nada menos este acuerdo a través del
cual el Reino Unido salió de la Unión
Europea El fabricante de automóviles
estelantes advirtió que las plantas
británicas Se podrían ver obligadas a
cerrar y a perder también miles de
puestos de trabajo esto si el gobierno
no renegocia el acuerdo de inmediato por
qué lo va a explicar el propietario de
marcas como Peugeot y Fiat Pues detalló
que el acuerdo actual impone aranceles
de exportación a furgonetas eléctricas
en Europa hacia Europa a partir del
próximo año cuando entren en vigor estas
reglas más estrictas posteriores al
brexit lo que están diciendo es que
quieren evitarse el pago de estos
aranceles Pues todos sabemos que mayores
aranceles un mayor precio de los
vehículos y lo que dicen es que si se
vuelven menos competitivos con respecto
a los autos que están vendiendo dentro
de la Unión Europea sobre todo ahora que
les están dando más gavelas tributarias
pues van a tener que cerrar sus puertas
al respecto se refirió el ministro el
Primer Ministro británico desde Japón en
donde va a reunirse con los otros
líderes del g7
es algo que los fabricantes de
automóviles de toda Europa no solo de
Reino Unido han planteado como una
preocupación y como resultado de eso
estamos comprometidos en un diálogo con
la Unión Europea sobre Cómo podemos
abordar esas preocupaciones y nuestra
cifra del día de hoy Cuál es bueno
Andrés Ustedes creyente sí y pagaría
Cuánto por una Biblia no Depende depende
de cuánto sea depende de Cuántos años
tenga la Biblia Bueno también pues Mire
mi cifra
del día a los 38 millones de dólares en
que fue subastada en Nueva York esta
Biblia hebrea que están viendo ustedes
en su pantalla pues le cuento que tiene
mil cien años de antigüedad uno de los
manuscritos más antiguos y valiosos
también del mundo se cree que el llamado
codex es azul o fue impreso en algún
momento entre los años 880 y
960 además Andrés recibió su nombre en
1929 cuando fue comprado por David
solomon sasun quien era hijo de un
Magnate de los negocios judío ir aquí
que llenó su casa de Londres con una
colección de manuscritos judíos vale la
pena los 38 millones y los tuviéramos
bueno Y también depende del valor que
estas personas le dan a este tipo de
objetos también y del valor que venga
después porque según estaba leyendo esta
Biblia hace unos años valía poco menos
de 10 millones de dólares hoy vale 30 y
casi 30 y casi 39 millones de dólares
por los que fue subastado en Nueva York
por la casa de subastas
con más noticias económicas Muchas
gracias aquí nos vemos